hiv leads to hundreds of thousands of
deaths a year
and there's no vaccine despite decades
of research
that very research has seen several
covert vaccines developed at lightning
speed
the coronavirus is pretty
straightforward
hiv is a master of disguise and mutates
incredibly quickly
[Music]
but recent breakthroughs provide hope
welcome to the show i'm ben fazoulen
mrna technology
could be the game changer i'll talk to a
scientist working on the latest
developments in a moment
first this report
scientists were able to develop
effective vaccines within months of the
outbreak of the coronavirus pandemic
for two reasons firstly developed
countries poured
billions into vaccine development in
record time
and secondly scientists were able to
build on decades of
aids and cancer research the mrna
vaccines developed by moderna
and biontech are proof of that
the idea behind these genetic vaccines
is that people are injected with a
blueprint
for a particular element of the virus in
the case of the coronavirus this is
known as
the spike protein the process means the
body starts producing these proteins
itself
the immune system then recognizes that
it's coming under attack
and starts to fight back no vaccine has
been found against aids
which weakens the immune system because
hi viruses mutate so quickly
they also attack the immune system
directly which means the body is unable
to fight back
but the data and experimental results
gained during research into coronavirus
vaccines
have also given the search for an aids
vaccine a terrific
boost scientists have been able to
obtain a lot of new data in a short time
the first positive results are already
being seen
modana is planning to begin two clinical
trials of its
mrna hiv vaccines by the end of this
year
nigel garrett is head of vaccine and
pathogenesis research at the center for
the aids program of research
in south africa or capresa so many
hiv vaccine trials have failed miserably
what makes you think that these new
trials stand a better chance of success
good afternoon to you ben and to your
viewers thank you so much for inviting
me um
now just to say that at the moment there
are two ongoing hiv vaccine trials
interestingly they're using the
adenovirus
vector platform which is also used in
the
johnson johnson corvit vaccine
the mrna technology is is obviously new
um and has been applied to corvette
vaccines but
not yet to hiv in in human trials
so so we're really looking forward to
that
um there's some key differences between
hiv
and sas core v2 so perhaps we're going
to discuss that a bit
so this is where hiv is benefiting
from from covert would you say because
in so many cases during this pandemic
research into other diseases including
hiv aids has taken quite a hit because
of the focus on covert
yeah so that's right some of our
research here at capresa has shown that
the
number of testing has reduced by about
50 percent hiv testing and also then
hiv treatment initiation and you know
everyone knows that the hiv treatment is
really key
for keeping people healthy and and
prevent death
so these are key unaids targets
um so we suspect and hypothesize that
there's been a lot of diversion
of resources staffing and also
laboratory resources to cover testing
in in many middle-income countries so
nigel do we have the covert vaccines
because it's a virus that affects the
whole world and
not just a certain minority of the
population in so many countries as is
the case with hiv aids
um yeah so this was obviously a pandemic
that hit
absolutely everyone across the globe and
it's been a
huge huge effort globally
and a massive mobilization so many of
the hiv researchers have also
actually helped with running these
trials because we
had these clinical trial platforms all
set up
across the world really and so in terms
of hiv there has been
funding over the years it's just a much
more difficult virus
to find an hiv vaccine against than
corvette
with covet we were very lucky that we
found the right target which is the
spike protein on the covet and we
managed to elicit
very strong antibodies against the spike
protein that
the virus uses to attach to these
epithelial cells in the lung
in hiv that is a lot more complicated
we've been comparing it to covert but in
comparison to
something like the flu i think people
find it interesting
the the variability of hiv in an
individual exceeds the global
sequence variability in the influenza
virus during
a whole season is that what makes hiv so
hard to fight
yeah so you're right ben there's a
enormous genetic diversity in hiv
so if you look at the sequences that for
example
encode the you know the shell of the
virus
they can vary by up to maybe about 35
between viruses of the same type of hiv
and then there's very high what they
call mutation rates so
the virus itself then evolves very
quickly in a human being
well for example the corvette vaccine or
other flu
viruses um they may have you know maybe
quite stable like 95 of the genome may
be very stable and it's just
one or two mutations that may change and
then you know you
obviously then also get the problem with
the famous variants yes
and the vast majority of hiv infected
individuals only produce weak strain
specific antibodies but some rare
individuals do make
potent antibodies against a broad range
of
mutations those antibodies are highly
unusual but scientists do have them in
their possession don't they
yeah so this is actually a very
interesting
part of hiv research currently so
caprice has been involved in a lot of
broadly neutralizing antibody research
which are these
very strong antibodies they have been
isolated in some rare individuals as you
say
and we've been managing to essentially
make them now
in in the bioreactors and we can give
them to human beings
as what they call passive immunization
which is not a vaccine but it's
giving the antibody directly for hiv
prevention
now the real challenge is now to elicit
these antibodies through a vaccine
and i think that's again where maybe
mrna vaccines could
come in because they have the potential
they they're very easy to manufacture
and quite
cheap as well they can be delivered with
these
lipid nanoparticles to the body and then
the body can
make so-called immune proteins so
we call them immunogens and
administering multiple immunogens could
then elicit potentially
the making of these strong antibodies in
a human being
in natural infection it takes about
three years in an hiv-infected person to
elicit these very strong antibodies so
it's a continuous evolving
antibody race with the virus that's been
also quite well described
so nigel let me ask you just ask you
briefly
the question i asked you at the very
beginning how much hope do you have them
uh considering the mrna technology
that's been developed and
these other breakthroughs so i'm
extremely excited like many of my
colleagues about the technology
there have been some animal studies
already that have
shown some efficacy of these
of these mrna vaccines for
to prevent the the monkey equivalent of
hiv
and we are looking forward to some human
trials i think as you
all know maybe some of your viewers as
well madonna's interested in this
technology and taking this forward
so i think we have great hope that this
will
help us on the path to an hiv vaccine
soon
excellent great to hear nigel garrett
from caprico there good to have you on
the show today
thank you ben let's check in now with
derek williams on the topic of covert
vaccines stealing the spotlight
does covid19 vaccine production compete
with the production of other vaccines
although vaccine manufacture is such a a
vital cog
in the machinery of global health care i
found it
surprisingly difficult to nail down firm
numbers when i began
researching this topic hard information
on production figures was was pretty
scarce
and and the supply chains involved are
pretty
convoluted um however non-covet vaccine
manufacture has i think
certainly taken a hit as resources
continue to be thrown
at stopping sars kovi ii even
straightforward bottlenecks
like shortfalls for instance in medical
grade
glass vials they will have serious
knock-on effects and and the massive
wave of of cobit 19
in india which is often called the
pharmacy of the world
because so many vaccines are made there
that will in the very nature of things
cause production slowdowns for other
vaccines
as as resources are diverted to the
production
of covet vaccines but even if
manufacturers are
are making less vaccine for other
diseases
supply side issues are just one part
of a looming problem which is that in
the course of the pandemic
demand for those other vaccines also
dropped a lot
new data from the cdc for instance shows
that
in the u.s last year routine
childhood vaccinations for things like
measles or tetanus
fell dramatically as parents skipped
appointments afraid that they
or their kids might contract covet 19
at a doctor's office or at a clinic and
the same thing will have occurred
in many other parts of the world experts
warn that
all of those missed childhood
vaccinations
will be difficult to make up and and say
that in the midterm
that could lead to spikes in the number
of cases
for diseases that before the pandemic
were kept in check by vaccines
and some more good news before we go
fully vaccinated people in germany can
now get a digital certificate on their
cell phones to prove their status
health minister yen span says the goal
is for the passport to be available
by the end of the month of the latest to
everyone who qualifies
it's intended to allow holders more
freedom in the pandemic
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon